hi this is presh talwalkar in this video
i'm going to teach you a math trick of
how to divide numbers by connecting the
dots
let's say you want to divide 133
342
by and twenty-one
while this looks like a challenging
problem it will be a cinch if you divide
by connecting the dots
to start out we're going to draw dots
for each digit of the number that we
want to divide by
starting with the digit 1 we're going to
draw one dot
for the next digit 3 we're going to draw
three dots
we're going to continue drawing dots
corresponding to each digit of the
number that we want to divide by
once we've drawn all the dots we're
ready to connect the dots
the number we're dividing by is 121
so that means we want to connect one dot
to two dots to one more dot
starting from the far left let's connect
one dot
to two dots to one more dot
we'll continue doing this for the
remaining dots connecting one dot
to two dots to one more dot
and we'll continue doing this we'll
continue connecting one dot to two dots
to one more dot until all the dots are
filled in
now we can count out the number of
completed figures we have to get to our
answer
so starting with the column on the far
left there's one completed figure that
starts in this column
so we write a one
moving one column over
the first two dots correspond to a
figure that's already started it's only
the third dot that counts for a new
figure
so we wanna so in this column
we also have one figure that starts out
in this column
going to the third column
all of the dots correspond to figures
that have already started so there are
no figures that have started in this
column
and finally in the fourth column
we can see the first two dots correspond
to figures that start in that column
so that's a two
we can now take these numbers to get to
our answer
which is one thousand one hundred and
two
and you can check that's the correct
answer
this is an interesting method and what's
even more interesting is we can use it
for algebraic expressions
so let's say you want to divide 2x
squared plus three x plus one
by the quantity x plus one
we're going to start out by drawing dots
corresponding to the number we want to
divide by
so for two x squared we draw two dots
for three x we draw three dots
and for one we draw one dot
for the number we want to divide by x
plus one
we need to connect one dot
to one other dot
so we'll start out with the dots in the
figure
we'll connect one dot to another dot
we can do that one more time
and for the remaining dots we can draw
one more line
now we can get to our answer by counting
the number of figures that start in each
column
for the column on the far left
there are two figures that start in that
column
moving one spot over
there's one figure that starts in that
column
so that gets us to our answer of two x
plus one
i hope you like this video please
subscribe to my channel you can catch me
on my blog mindyourdecisions or on
twitter at preshtalwalker
and also if you like this video i think
you'll really like my video about how to
multiply numbers by drawing lines
you should watch that video and you can
also check out the book
that's on amazon.com